first of all you're watching
that interview uh with the uh is
defector with stuart ramsey uh what did
you make of what he had to say well i
think first of all it
what i most took from that was it
demonstrated the importance
of getting people from within terrorist
organizations
who become disillusioned and who are
then prepared to speak out and cooperate
part of your program was saying how cage
and other apologists for jihadi john
were saying he was radicalized because
the intelligence agencies approached him
well if they did approach him it was
partly i suspect to see
was he a convinced extremist
or might he be someone who had become
disillusioned because that does happen
from time to time and it's the single
most important source of real
intelligence you can get someone who's
been in the organization who might
indeed still be in a terrorist
organization but be prepared to
cooperate but what about the counter to
that that it people do feel that they're
spied on it might alienate them i mean i
know cage have said that but other other
people have said that there's an answer
to that which is a very obvious answer
in a way
why are the intelligence agencies taking
an interest in them in the first place
yeah they don't take an interest in
people who don't already have a
reputation for extremist opinions now
there is a difference between people
with extremist opinions who don't commit
acts of violence and those who do yeah
and but you can never tell that
it's obviously a difficult question but
again we have the parents of
one of the girls who's gone they're
saying that she was terrified when she
realized that the police were taking an
interest in her yes but it does have to
beg the question why were they taking an
interest in her they don't do it at
random they don't go on fishing
expeditions at any given time the
intelligence agencies in the united
kingdom have about probably three to
four thousand names on their files of
people who are known to have extremist
opinions now only a small proportion of
them will go on to commit acts of
terrorist violence but you never know
that at the beginning of the stage and
most of the radicalization that takes
place nowadays isn't in the mosques it's
on the internet it is people uh like for
example adam alawe and adobe who killed
uh lee rigby uh they were radicalized by
contacts they had on the internet with
people in the middle east and are you
convinced as uh the foreign secretaries
and he said so in his speech that if the
conservatives are returned to power
there really need to be much stronger
intrusive powers
for the authorities i would hope whoever
has returned to power would come to that
conclusion i mean to be fair to the
labour party
labour governments were not soft on
terrorism they recognized as as to the
liberal democrats everyone does
but the incumbent government has a
responsibility whoever is that
government and they have to accept and
realize
that we are facing a threat that could
happen at any time i mean there have
been two serious terrorist threats in
the united kingdom each year that have
been disrupted by our intelligence
agencies and law enforcement agencies so
this isn't hypothetical it's already
happening mr hammond today praising the
intelligence services for their hard
work i think few would doubt that they
work hard but actually
when you look at what's happened with is
when you look at uh the way in which
russia has evolved over the last two
years
we did miss it didn't we you don't
always anticipate what's going to happen
because sometimes the people in the
country is concerned don't anticipate
what's going to happen think of the arab
spring for example which began in libya
and in tunisia and egypt even the
tunisians and egyptians didn't exist but
that makes the question what's what you
know what's the value of intelligence
well i can answer that if i may uh the
primary value is to identify individuals
who are a threat to our interests either
through terrorism or espionage or
reasons of that kind there's a wider
role for the intelligence agencies which
is to collect information which might
indicate what heads of governments that
are unfriendly may be up to maybe
planning that's much more difficult
that's much more difficult sometimes our
agencies do get it wrong for example on
on the falklands that was a huge uh
error a huge area of incompetence the
bletchley park however is the world when
britain broke the german naval code that
is the world's best
intelligence achievement of all time and
where do you think it went wrong
with russia you were of course in the
government for the
early part of that
where do we take the wrong turning in
being true complacent or too trusting no
i think what people overlook is that the
what happened at the end of the cold war
wasn't one event
it was several events it was the end of
the cold war it was the end of communism
versus capitalism but most important in
the current context it was the end of
europe's last empire the russian empire
and what putin has never
acknowledged or be prepared to accept
because russian leaders believe that to
protect russia they have to control what
they call the near abroad the countries
around them and that's not acceptable in
the modern europe and this is the
dilemma we face in europe putin with a
lot of support in russia believes that
they have a right to interfere with the
independence of ukraine you say that now
but i mean i remember
going on visits to russia with british
prime ministers who saw him as a
continuation after yeltsin
gorbachev of leaders who wanted to be
friendly with that that's what clearly
doesn't well and we made a big mistake
in the first period of putin's rule
he brought back stability yeltsin's rule
had been rather chaotic rather anarchic
putin represented stability he was also
fortunate you've got to have a lot of
luck at that level in politics and he
was lucky that the russian economy was
the oil price and the matters of that
kind was taking off so he was able to
produce stability and he was able to
produce prosperity of the kind the
russians hadn't seen before but
ultimately do never forget he was
beforehand a kgb policeman and once a
kgbc
we basically were too complacent i don't
think we were complacent but i think i
think there were some mistakes yeah i
think all the talk about whether ukraine
should join nato or not was ridiculous i
don't think there was ever a serious
argument for that in the first place and
do you think the fact that uh the
outgoing government won't commit
to the nato spending target on defense
somewhat undercuts
all that uh philip hammond was saying
about it i'm very i'm very very worried
about that indeed because you know it's
not just a question of having the right
armed forces which are expensive it is
that your whole foreign policy will not
have an impact you will not have the
influence required if you don't have a
military capability as well there's a
marvelous quotation from frederick the
great uh the diplomacy without arms is
like music without instruments and that
remains true not because you always want
to use your arms but you always have to
have that option if the person you're
negotiating with is aggressive and
opportunistic so you would say that
you'd advise your i mean your
conservative mp
you would advise the party
to honor uh that spending pledge in the
in the uh yeah at the end of the day the
crucial
question is not a precise percentage
yeah it is whether you provide enough
cash i mean what is absurd at the moment
i've got nothing against overseas aid
but the idea that we are committed i'm
going to be committed by law to
increasing overseas aid over the next
couple of years uh
to ensure that it remains at 0.7 when we
are actually going to be facing further
cuts is the height of a responsibility
and as far as oversight is concerned the
intelligence committee is very important
you've announced that you're stepping
down are you still doing that job right
now i'm i'm still on the committee i i i
was due to stop being chairman but four
weeks time because we we end when the
parliament finishes so i stepped down
about three four weeks before i was
going to anyway but i'm on the committee
we're publishing a very very important
report on privacy and security arising
out of the snowden controversies just in
a couple of days time so i think that
will be something worth following